yeah I remember going to like the Great
Wall of China and it was it's got to be
packed
when like shoulder to shoulder man I was
looking at one of the greatest like one
of the greatest things man kind of has
ever built and all I can think it's
pretty it's pretty [ __ ] long in it
yeah that was the takeaway
it's
like
I really sort of thing it was like a
news article these two boys are running
across the Great Wall of Trials like
I'll be there [ __ ] long is it and I
googled it I was like [ __ ] hell it's
long
I'm pretty sure still would have been
great yeah genuinely like I someone
should have told them hey this is
overkill how long is the greatest 100
miles holy [ __ ] right am I crazy it's
like 100 miles something right instead
of done 20 miles pretty sure it still
would have been pretty great okay I I
see why they call it the Great Wall not
just the world
it's not the okay
it's not the good ball
it's not the Big Wall of China
it's pretty great how long does the wall
need to be great that's the resource
Museum What's the cutoff between good
and great so total length of the
sections of the Great Wall of China and
it adds up to a thousand uh 13
171 miles isn't that insane third yeah
so 21
196 kilometers yeah I see I I wouldn't
be [ __ ] even I thought 100 was I
thought it was 100 why did they not call
it the Giga Wall of China it's more than
Gray that's [ __ ] insane yeah to think
about everything being being on the
actual war with uh like especially in
like one of the big entrances yeah you
don't think that at all you're like well
have you seen like um there's a series
that uh with Carl Pilkington yeah where
he basically just made this guy who uh
if you don't like carpool because it's
kind of this very average British man
right who just doesn't like anything
yeah and so it sounds like a typical
story for us yeah he forced him to get
all this touristy stuff and he just
hated it all right and dude they made
the Great Wall of China and that episode
looks so Bleak and awful they made it
because it's just like he's on this bus
on the way to it and it's just a bunch
of like people like spitting yeah and
stuff like it made it like seem really
Bleak and kind of like oh before you get
there there's trash everywhere and it's
just like it's packed one thing
um that I've not seen anyone talk about
uh the Great Wall of China
um so I I remember
um the entrance that I went on the Great
Wall of China it's it was it was is one
of the most popular kind of places
because obviously the Great Wall is
[ __ ] massive yeah there's I'm sure
there's a lot more aesthetic pleasing
places where do you walk and then get
out another section or do you walk and
then turn back around uh so you walk and
then there's a station and then there's
a cable car that takes you up to the
Great Wall of China technology yeah
which is uh not very ancient China I'm
sure they didn't have that in the
[ __ ]
um hand Dynasty or whatever but you know
um but there's a cable car that takes
you up so you're stuck you're you're
basically stuck on there until you can
take the cable car back down right
um so you go up and it's it's [ __ ]
rammed right yeah it's absolutely uh
absolutely round with tourists and the
Cobblestone there's been so many
tourists that the Cobblestone is just
smooth like there there were steps there
were steps but it was more like a slide
right because because they had been
eroded so much by so many people walking
on walking on the stones right Jesus the
one thing people don't talk about really
talk about the history or something uh
which is which is amazing the history
is [ __ ] insane you go up there the
first thing I noticed is that something
smells funny right it's not something
something something smells funny in the
air and I can't can't I can't pinpoint
it right
um but then I see him realize what this
funny smell was I went in summer by the
way
um I went in summer
um so I uh on this wall since we're
stuck on the wall we you have to go take
a cable car down to get off the wall and
obviously the line's [ __ ] massive
um I didn't go to the toilet before
going on the Great Wall of China
um of course there'd be no toilet and
the Great Wall of China yeah why would
they why would they install Plumbing
yeah so obviously obviously in hindsight
you're like yeah of course obviously
they um they didn't have Plumbing back
in the the ancient China but since this
is a heavy touristy Place obviously
there's going to be some public toilets
there are they like porta potties or
something oh
yeah and uh I I don't know how they get
[ __ ] off the Great Wall of China but a
lot of [ __ ] stays on the Great Wall of
China and walking towards the public
toilet was one of the worst it was it
was like a Dark Souls boss right you
know you you like just to get through
the public toilet you have to like see
the gates of mortal yeah you have to
[ __ ] fight through a wall of stench
as you're like walking towards this
quarter pot like this this group of
port-a-potties like the poison it was
yeah because like I was like I can hold
my breath but you needed to be like an
Olympic diver to hold your breath for
long enough to get close enough to like
go to the toilet and go out it was it
was one of the worst Dentures I've ever
felt like
um disgusting it's uh yeah if you're
gonna go to the Great Wall of China I
highly recommend not going to the heavy
touristy places before as well and take
a [ __ ] before as well it's because it's
it's an amazing piece of human it looks
amazing I really wanted a butter God
[ __ ] damn it like the the heavily
tourist spots are just it's it's a
nightmare I mean for how long the Wall
is there must be like blank spots right
where you can go to the wall and there's
maybe like barely anyone there I don't
know I don't know like I don't know how
much of the wall is actually accessible
to the public right like I'm sure
there's a lot of possible like close I
think I think a lot of them all is like
is closed up for like government
protection yeah like that there's only
some parts of the wall that you can go
to but there are less busier parts right
um it just so happens that the part
that's closest to Beijing is obviously
like the uh yeah of course the most
populated part and uh the most stinkiest
part of them all and the father I don't
recommend going to even if it is the
Great Wall of China because it's not a
it's it's not a pleasant experience it's
interesting yeah what was the best
tourist spot that you went to like one
whereas like it didn't make you feel
like the kind of bleakness of like oh
this is just a tourist place that's like
taking me for you know taking my money
you know for the sake of whatever
because you know like we've talked about
like how you know you guys don't really
like going to like the heavily touristy
places just for because of the feeling
there's one place I don't know about the
best touristy place I I have been to but
the one place I do want to go to because
that everyone says is as insane as it
looks is the Sistine Chapel oh in the
Vatican yeah in the Vatican I've I've
been there
um it's actually really [ __ ] cool
yeah yeah like you don't even have to
confusion
no I was trying to remember I was like
that's that's the Sistine Channel all
right yeah no I went there um when I
went to Italy with Aki's family
um yeah it's really cool I mean
obviously you have to wait in line for a
long time but the cool thing is that
they limit how many people can go in
okay so when you actually go inside
because of the the scale of the building
yeah there's only so many people who are
inside of there so it's actually quite
spacious like you can actually like
probably walk around and you know feel
like the the just the massiveness of the
thing yeah and like I mean you don't
even have to be religious but like the
moment you walk in you just like you
just feel something it's just like this
is like it really is like the most holy
place and it's just I don't know it's
it's such a world you're a holy man no
not at all not at all but even then like
be me being in there it just felt so
like is that permanent
dudes going oh no no
because I I was tempted because
how echoey it is in there but like even
then like I couldn't even like someone
else joined in when you started I looked
around and I was like on my Lads with me
no not today unfortunately but like yeah
just I don't know like even if you're
not religious in the slightest um like I
don't know there's just like this very
strange feeling you get being in there
being like wow this is a very powerful
spot and I can't explain I feel like
that's how like historical Sports and
exhibitions should make yeah I agree and
I feel like a lot of it just get diluted
down by I guess the over
commercialization and the over Taurus
I don't know what the word what I'm
looking for tourist vacation tourists
touristification
we just made that up there but uh yeah
that that kind of thing where you tell
you have this really really nice place
and then it just gets over touristy yeah
um and then it kind of just ruins that I
can't think of a single place that was
super touristy that I actually enjoyed
yeah I think I just prefer just going to
a city or a place I'm just eating and
drinking the food I think after this
like a million times a trash taste yeah
it's like over it I'm a simple man I am
a food and a drink kind of guy yeah I
mean like I I'm also definitely that as
well but if I have the opportunity to
see even just for like a split second
like some kind of touristy section of
that City or whatever like you know
unless it's like super [ __ ] boring or
like I just don't really care like I'll
try and make an effort to go check it
out I mean there's been a lot of
instances where like I've gone to it and
I'm like oh that's kind of underwhelming
like when I went to the Coliseum and
stuff like that I was just like like you
think about the Coliseum it's like oh
this is [ __ ] amazing piece of
architecture and when I went there I was
like
yeah it looks pretty cool anyway see see
here's the thing Joey here's the thing I
don't take pictures
ah I don't post on Instagram yeah so why
would I need to go to 90 of these spots
that people go to I'll need to take a
picture to say that they've been there
yeah you know but you know what's weird
I weirdly actually don't take pictures
in the touristy spots
because I feel that's like like everyone
does that already right so it's like I
don't mean the [ __ ] toilet
you want to do that anymore like I
rather just take like a picture of like
a normal part of the city or a normal
part of the environment because that's
like more of a I guess like genuine view
of where you are yeah whereas like if I
if if I said like yeah I went to Italy
guys and I took a picture inside the
Sistine Chapel and the [ __ ] and you
know and the Colosseum and everything
then it'll be like okay yeah but like
how is that any different to anybody
else's experience the colosseums look so
[ __ ] yeah I didn't even I didn't even
bother going in because there was like a
six hour line and I'm like what I'm good
dog I'm I'm looking it from the outside
yeah it looks pretty sick all right
let's go get some pizza like I mean I
didn't give a [ __ ] yeah I did I like
Italy a lot but madjo Rome oh I didn't
like Rome either
North Italy or something trying to eat
some food yeah I took more pictures in
like Florence than I did in Monroe
because it's just like a nicer City just
in general
and it's like there's nothing like
touristy there that I went to but just
like the vibe of that city was just so
much good food though yeah just like
better food and just like the vibe was
better and the people were better it's
just like so much more of an interesting
experience than seeing the [ __ ]
Coliseum yeah every day I just want to
eat food
I believe you just described all living
things
hey I'm unique what can I say